[موسيقى]
نحاول تخطي حدود المكونات التي
يمكن استخدامها في
كوكتيل تستخدمه والجنادب - الكيمتشي وقد
استخدمنا حتى سمك السلمون رو في أحد الكوكتيلات الخاصة بنا ،
فنحن أحد البارات الوحيدة
في العالم التي تركز على  باستخدام
المكونات بالطريقة التي نقوم بها ،
اسمي Vijay Medallia وأنا مالك مشارك
لشريط كوكتيل ارتداء أصلي مقره في
سنغافورة يركز على العمل مع
أربعة مكونات ،
لذلك كنت أبحث عن الطعام منذ حوالي ثلاث
سنوات حتى الآن كنادل أصغر  كنت
دائمًا مهتمًا بمكوِّن فريد
ومهم ، فالبيئة في
سنغافورة متنوعة تمامًا في بعض الأحيان
نقوم ببعض البحث عن الطعام في المناطق الحضرية ،
كما نخرج أيضًا إلى مناطق الغابات وننزل أيضًا
إلى الخطوط الساحلية للحصول على
أشياء مثل الأعشاب البحرية والمحار
باستخدام بعض  من هذه المكونات غير المعتادة ،
يمكننا الحصول على نكهات معينة مثيرة للاهتمام ،
تحتوي نهايات العلف على سبيل المثال على
حمض الفورميك ، لذلك عندما تفرقعها
تتذوق مثل القليل من الليمون الحامض أو الليمون
بسبب حموضة الجراد.
يخرج مثل
نكهة ميسو فيجيمايت الصويا وهي
ملاحظة لذيذة حقيقية لها ، وتستمر عملية صنع الكوكتيل لدينا
لمدة ستة أشهر ، وعادة ما
تبدأ من فكرة تستند إلى
موقع ثقافة التقاليد أو
البيئة ، على سبيل المثال ، كوكتيل البيراناكان الخاص بنا
قائم على
ثقافة البيراناكان المحلية مستوحاة من
إحدى الحلويات التي تسمى سلطة الرصيف ،
نستخدم الباندان وأوراق اللاكسا من
مزارع عضوي محلي من الكاكايا ،
لذلك نستخدم حليب الجاك فروت المغطى بالأعلاف أيضًا
حليب الماعز من متعة الله المحلية
والإنزيمات الموجودة في الكاكايا.  يخثّر
الحليب ونحصل على كوكتيل واضح نحاول
دمج تلك المكونات التي
تم استخدامها ثقافيًا لأكثر من مائة
عام
[موسيقى]
ما أحبه في دمج
مكونات Forge هو أنه يسمح لنا
بفهم بيئتنا بشكل أفضل
والعثور على منسي  المكونات في
ثقافتنا نأمل في السنوات القليلة المقبلة
أن تبدو فكرة البحث عن الطعام جديدة جدًا
وأعتقد أن الناس يريدون تجربة
موقعهم و  عندما يسافر الناس
حول العالم ، فإنهم يريدون أن يكون لديهم إحساس
بالهوية في المكان الذي يتواجدون فيه